uh-huh overlooking old wounds by
reinforcing ancient ties China Japan and
South Korea presented a united front
during the trilateral summit in China's
southern city of Chengdu I want to build
a new era of three kingdoms in which we
cooperate and develop together with the
international community setting aside
deep grievances dating back to World War
two the leaders of Asia's largest
economies pledged to work closer
together on trade they want to agree on
a 16 nation regional comprehensive
economic partnership or RCEP by the end
of next year and continue negotiations
on a three nation free trade agreement
trade between South Korea Japan and
China exceeded 720 billion dollars in
2018 Jerusalem for hire we need to
protect the free trade in order to help
business activities and continue to grow
together North Korea carrying out a
missile test over the Christmas period
overshadowed some of the pageantry
Chinese Prime Minister Lee kichan South
Korean president moon jae-in and
japanese prime minister shinzo other
agreed to continue supporting
negotiations between Washington and
Pyongyang Pyongyang's demand for the
u.s. to lift economic sanctions has led
to a halt in their nuclear talks and an
interview deadline to progress the
negotiations is fast approaching China
is North Korea's most important ally and
sees itself as playing a central role in
working towards denuclearization on the
Korean Peninsula Beijing has urged the
United Nations to lift sanctions on
Pyongyang to help break the deadlock but
it's unclear whether Seoul or Tokyo both
US allies would support that move on
Monday moon jae-in and she's Arvind that
separately with Chinese President Xi
Jinping in Beijing for China the summit
is an opportunity to expand its regional
influence but the three countries are
currently embroiled in territorial
disputes in the South China Sea Hawaii
South Korea and Japan are allies with
the u.s. so if China can develop and
improve the relations with these two
countries the well decrease US influence
in this region and a weakened China's
pressure from the US
the leaders have signed a ten-year
corporation plan which includes tackling
shared challenges such as climate change
and aging populations but the biggest
challenge perhaps is whether they can
view each other with trust rather than
as threats at rhenium aljazeera Beijing
[Applause]